Scott Adams The Man Behind the Dilbert
cartoon had a successful career as of
this past Friday emphasis on had his
comic strip was published in hundreds of
newspapers thousands I think actually
emphasis on was today his career is
effectively over in the span of two or
three days he was dropped by every major
newspaper and most of the non-major ones
too and then finally last night dumped
by Andrews McNeil Universal which is
Dilbert's longtime distributor they also
have severed ties with Scott Adams it's
one of the fastest and most thorough
cancellations we've yet seen rivaled
perhaps only by the short span of time
when Kanye West lost well over half his
net worth I think even more than that
for Scott Adams his cancellation was
prompted by comments that he made on his
YouTube live stream and this was a live
stream that he that published published
I think on Wednesday and then and then
for whatever reason took a couple days
before people noticed it and then they
noticed it and he was canceled on this
live stream he advised that white people
should quote get the hell away from
black people he warned that there's no
fixing this and that quote White
Citizens can no longer help quote black
citizens
now if you're curious about the this
he's referring to what exactly we can't
fix according to Adams the daily wire
covers that in its report quote
in a real coffee with Scott Adams video
posted on Wednesday Adams discussed a
Rasmussen poll that nearly half of black
Americans were unable to agree with the
phrase it's okay to be white Adam's
video in which he suggested that poll
results indicate that blacks are a quote
hate group went viral Adams in the video
joked that he's been identifying as
black for some time but must have
accidentally joined a hate group based
on a recent Rasmussen poll the poll
which surveyed a thousand people showed
that 53 of black people agreed with the
statement it's okay to be white leaving
47 unable to say they agree
now
call me a contrarian I've been told I've
been called worse than that and but it
would seem to me that the headline of
this story
is not what the Dilbert guy said on some
YouTube video given that he's just one
guy expressing a Viewpoint that is
clearly rejected by every powerful
institution in our society
but rather the story is the survey which
would seem to indicate widespread racial
animosity in the American population
so when I heard this that's the first
thing that I noticed I said well wait a
second what about this survey
the mainstream media would have us
believe that the roundly rejected and
condemned opinion of one man is a
greater concern and a much more urgent
National crisis than the racist
viewpoints revealed in the poll that he
was reacting to
but I would argue that we should
probably take some time I mean once
everyone has had their turn jumping on
the Scott Adams dog pile and I think by
now everyone has had their turn because
that's where the cancellation goes like
one one guy says something that lots of
people don't like and then uh and then
everyone jumps on it it's like even
after three or four days and 10 million
people have already jumped on the
Dogpile and said I too disagree with
this statement I think it's horrible
still you got someone else has to come
along and say I also disagree
well now that we've done that
um
can we talk about this survey and what
it purports to reveal
in fact I think the time to talk about
is probably right now so let's do that
looking at that Rasmussen poll again
it asks respondents whether they agree
or disagree with the statement it's okay
to be white
now among black respondents a slim
majority which is 53 percent
strongly or somewhat agree that it's
okay to be white but 26 strongly or
somewhat disagree while 21 aren't sure
that leaves as we said 47 who cannot
definitively say that it's okay to be
white
which is to say they cannot agree that
white people should exist
because that would be the implication if
it's not okay to be a member of a
certain race then what you're saying is
that it's not okay that that race exists
in fact even among white people only 67
percent would strongly agree that it's
okay for them to be the race that they
are
another 14 somewhat agree is it okay to
be what you are maybe sort of
leaving 20 who cannot say that they
agree at all that it's okay for them to
be the race that they are
now if these numbers are accurate they
reveal a truly dangerous level of hatred
and animosity against whites and and and
even shared by a large percentage of
whites against themselves as well
now you could argue that this poll only
surveyed a thousand people doesn't
represent a true and accurate
cross-section of the American people
therefore you can also argue that
Rasmussen is a conservative firm I've
heard this on the left as well as it
conserves a right-wing firm and so they
conducted the survey in a way that would
skew the results in their ideological
favor
now on that second point if you're right
that they were skewing the results to
get you know to get the results that
they favor it only makes the results
more concerning after all Rasmussen
reported these results triumphantly as
an indication that most Americans reject
woke racial indoctrination
so if they were trying to prove anything
with the survey they were trying to
prove that anti-white racism is not
widespread
as that would show that normal Americans
reject wokeism their own headline about
the poll results that's what it declares
Americans reject uh woke racial
indoctrination
and yet even in that effort they
inadvertently showed the opposite
the sample size is small though you know
that I would Grant
but the whole science of polling is to
ascertain General sentiments by
quantifying the opinions of a small
group now your faith in that science or
pseudoscience may be rather limited I
mean I know that mine is
but I can't help but notice that many
people who regularly tout poll results
are when it comes to this particular
poll eager to declare that the results
must be wrong
I'm willing to listen to an argument
that the results are wrong because I'm
naturally skeptical of all polls that
would require contrary evidence right
evidence that anti-white beliefs are not
widespread
but I haven't seen any Skeptics Skeptics
provide such evidence so you could say
that well no there's no way that that
many uh black people feel that way about
white people or even at that many white
people feel that way about them there's
no way that's true okay well why do you
think it's not true
like what based on what you're assuming
that it's not true based on what do you
assume that
indeed the evidence seems to go the
other way
what makes the results especially
disturbing is that they are not a shock
that they don't seem to be an aberration
instead they can port with much of what
we see in society including from other
polls just recently The Washington Post
conducted their own survey finding that
70 percent of black Americans believe
that half of all whites
are white supremacists
over 49 of um
or rather over 40 percent of black
respondents claim that all or most
whites are white supremacists in fact
across two different polls the number of
black Americans who believe that it's
not okay to be white and that most white
people are white supremacists is almost
identical they're off by a few
percentage points that's either an
incredible coincidence or an indication
of something very troubling
we don't need polls you could see the
anti-white sentiment everywhere in plain
sight take this Infamous video which uh
happened to go viral this week as well
along with the Scott Adams stuff where
anti-white racism is casually paraded
right in front of our faces watch this
are white people's Superior at
[Laughter]
they want people to secure they're real
good at violence violence genocide it's
like stealing people's lives just
because they feel like it if you are
white and you know this is happening and
you say nothing then you're a killer too
what exactly are white people from here
you're at insecurity pretending fear
being fearful of nothing being ignorant
blame letting their egos control their
every move Superior at being
what exactly are white people Superior
at oppression gaslighting lack of
empathy intellectualizing oppression did
I say oppression what exactly are white
people Superior at taking what's not
there taking taking our ideas copycat
gentrification appropriating things that
do not belong to them taking over other
people's cultures and making you believe
that they invented it maybe they're
thinking as repurposing it's like
recycle and repurpose as my grandma was
saying the white folk they'll take it if
you don't copyright it they are very
good at destruction of land destruction
of people destruction of humanness
public can't really difficult really
conservative like white people are
really good at upholding white supremacy
how about claiming that you know they
are actually a whole separate race when
actually white DNA comes from the black
female so what exactly are white people
Superior honey lion stealing and
cheating manipulation withholding
information lying telling lies
hmm
uh now the point is not just what the
bigots in the video said uh it's that
the video exists in the first place you
would never see a mainstream Outlet or
even a non-mainstream outlet uh produce
and publish a video with the races
swapped and that is so obvious that it's
become a truism the racial double
standard is so apparent that even people
who oppose the double standard get sick
of hearing others point it out because
you know like we know it
but the global standard is so clear to
everyone is yet more evidence to support
the results of the poll
the reaction to Scott Adams proves it
too now we all know that if Scott had
darker skin and had instead been
advising blacks to get the hell away
from whites
he would not have lost a single
newspaper if anything he would have
gained a few more
we know for a this is not this is not me
assuming this we know for a fact that
it's true because race Hustlers on the
other side regularly declare that black
people are not safe around white people
and this is something that's said all
the time despite the fact that there is
zero evidence to support that
this is something that's always said and
none of the people who say that ever
suffer the slightest consequence for
saying so
why well because
the most powerful forces in our society
have been working for years to get
exactly the results that we see in that
Rasmussen Bowl
that's perhaps the best evidence that
the poll Is tragically accurate because
it simply reveals the racial animosity
and anti-white hostility that our
culture has been dead set on instilling
in black and white people alike
it doesn't emerge from a vacuum kids
today are raised in schools and they
consume media and they watch films and
shows that all carry the explicit
message that white people are histories
great villains that white people are
inherently racist that whiteness is a
Scourge a disease
in fact a psychoanalyst named Donald
Moss published a paper a couple years
ago that argued explicitly that
here's the first line of the abstract in
this paper
whiteness is a condition one first
acquires and then one has a malignant
parasitic-like condition to which white
people have a particular susceptibility
the last line laments that despite their
best efforts they've yet to come up with
quote a permanent cure for whiteness
those are the exact words permanent cure
if that sounds genocidal it's because it
is
just like the statement it's not okay to
be white reveals genocidal hatred as
there is only one cure for a race that's
that it's not okay to be right if it's
not okay to be a member of a certain
race well how do you cure that what do
you do about that
this is what's brewing
one racial group has been tagged as the
enemy the cancer the cause of all our
social ills
far from the first time in history that
a racial group has been scapegoated in
this way
and so we know from history where it
leads
and I think perhaps this is what we
should really be talking about that'll
do it for this portion of shows move
over to the members block if you're not
a member yet you can become a member and
use code wall should check out for two
months free on all annual plans hope to
see you over there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]